tout être humain qui en raison de son
âge son état physique ou mental de sa
situation économique se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler a le droit
d'obtenir de la collectivité des moyens
convenables d'existence la lecture de ce
11e alinéa du Préambule de la
Constitution de 46 sonne pour nous tous
à l'heure de légiférer sur une énième
réforme de réduction du droit à une
retraite digne comme un rappel aux
valeurs fondamentales de notre
République
issue de notre histoire le préambule de
1946 fait partie intégrante de notre
bloc de constitutionnalité avec la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 ainsi que bien entendu
la Constitution de 1958 il reprend de
nombreux points du programme du Conseil
National de la Résistance
qui a permis la naissance de la sécurité
sociale et sous la direction du ministre
communiste Ambroise Croizat de la
création du régime de retraite par
répartition qui perdure aujourd'hui
encore
malgré les coups de boutoir des
partisans dogmatiques de la loi du
marché
cette réforme des retraites ou plutôt
cette destruction programmée de la
solidarité que porte la répartition
qu'Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement
tentent d'imposer à notre peuple et
profondément injuste elle est injuste
moralement alors que sur fond d'une
inflation galopante nos concitoyens se
remettent à peine d'une crise sanitaire
violente alors que notre peuple plonge
progressivement dans une précarité dans
le travail mais aussi dans la vie
quotidienne du logement à l'accès aux
soins alors que les uns et les autres
sont frappés d'horreur par la guerre qui
tue à nos portes vous ne trouvez rien de
mieux monsieur le monsieur les ministres
mais aussi Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle et sénatorial que de
demander à nos concitoyens de travailler
plus longtemps
violence quelle violence faite à ses
salariés souvent usée pas seulement du
fait de métier jugé pénible qui devront
travailler plus y compris après des
carrières bien longues quel violence
quelle violence faite aux femmes qui du
fait de leur parcours professionnel
heurté ou d'une plus grande exposition
au chômage partiel devront travailler
plus longtemps
d'emblée je dénonce je dénonce les
propositions que je juge pour ma part
insultante pour toutes les femmes de ce
pays émanant du président retaillod et
du groupe les républicains un sous
prétexte de vous préoccuper de la cause
des femmes vous les enfermez à quelques
jours du 8 mars dans un rôle de mère de
plus grandes familles possibles en
instaurant une prime à la maternité
préoccupez-vous plutôt
d'instaurer l'égalité salariale entre
les deux sexes cela assurera 6 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires de cotisations
sociales pour œuvrer contre tout nouveau
déficit à venir
[Musique]